[Applause]
hey
huh
[Applause]
hey
to the side to the side
because he's coming to me most people
and you're doing as well
step forward but you shouldn't know you
should step to the side
look at this handle
this is how it would really work
we won't do that
just hold down
okay
lift up
if he lifts up keep lifting
his angle
his angle you've got his angle here
you have a cigarette you can take your
time
there's just there's a little angle in
there
you have to put your mind you know like
I've seen the stretching this morning
but the breathing you know breathing to
the Joint even though the air doesn't
get here the breathing you can push the
muscle
with your breath it's the same here with
these angles
I don't really know why I'm telling it
really because it's like at my at my
level you should understand these very
very small angles
but down here I'm working on angle I can
just feel where he's going
and I'm just adjusting it as a secret
that is that's that's what you call
secrets
when you can see it
and one day you show me when when I'm
old and gray
lift
when you can do that with uh with the
knees then you can do it but don't do
that we'll just do this
hey
please try